Baby Driver’s five and a half minute opening
scene skillfully introduces us to the world
of the film, sets up some of the characters
and is one my favorite car chases in recent
cinema. It does all this without any exposition
or dialogue.
The scene has two parts. I’m going to talk
first about what Director Edgar Wright sets
up in the first half of the scene, and then
break down some of the techniques he uses
for the car chase in the second half.
Thank you to squarespace for sponsoring this
video.
A good filmmaker will carefully use what the
audience sees and hears first to set up the
world of the film. Edgar Wright Does this
well in Baby Driver. Even before we see anything,
we hear a high-pitched tone that fades into
a musical note. The viewer won’t find out
until much later in the film that Baby listens
to music because of his tinnitus, but the
seed of that idea is planted firmly at the
beginning.
In Baby Driver images are often subordinate
to sound, a reverse of the usual roles. So
it makes sense that we hear sound before we
see images, establishing sounds critical role
in the film.
The opening three shots quickly and easily
give us context for the world and setup the
main character.
We see cars and a bank, a sign telling us
what city we’re in, and then Baby’s red
subaru fills the screen, calling attention
to itself as the most important piece of this
scene. A sharp attentive audience that has
seen any marketing material for the film,
will probably be able to guess from this one
shot the scenario that’s being established
here, a bank robbery.
The second thing we see is Baby’s ipod.
This is the first step in establishing the
fact that the music in Baby Drivers soundtrack
is a part of the world. We’re hearing what
Baby’s hearing, the music isn’t just something
for the audience. By making this the second
shot of the movie, Wright is also emphasizing
the important role that music will play in
the film.
Finally we see Baby himself in a close-up.
Our main character.
After Baby hits play on the ipod each of the
next four cuts happen on beat with the music.
As the crew gets out of the car The slamming
of the car doors, opening and closing of the
trunk and their footsteps, as well as the
sounds of vehicles beeping and passing in
the street, all synchronize with the music.
So in the first seconds of the film the audience
is already introduced to the stylistic tic
that will propel much of the film.
At 48 seconds into the movie, the crew’s
masks go on and if you hadn’t managed to
guess the situation yet it’s very obvious
now.
This is where another important decision happens.
Even though the more interesting thing, the
movement of the action is moving into the
bank, Wright uses a telephoto shot, and perspective
to separate Baby from the crew, and we the
audience stay in the car with Baby.
This not only gets us comfortable with the
fact that the rest of the story will play
out from Baby’s perspective, it helps us
separate him from the seedy criminal world.
Baby is told later in the film that he “isn’t
part of this work”, and it’s an idea that
helps us sympathize with Baby’s situation.
To further establish this, Wright uses a sequence
of Baby signing and drumming along with the
song to juxtapose Baby’s attitude and demeanor
with what Baby is. Baby is a getaway driver,
but he acts more like a bored intern passing
the time.
Wright quickly reminds us however, that this
separation is just an illusion. The coincidence
of a passing police car awakens Baby from
his reverie. And Baby’s view of what’s
happening in the bank and the gunshot serve
as a harsh reminder for us and for Baby of
what he’s involved with.
The audience doesn’t know it yet but this
is the central conflict for his character.
Baby’s concern about his relationship to
this world of crime. And it’s not accident
on the director’s part that it’s during
this section that the camera is the closest
to Baby’s face that it’s been so far.
This close up emphasizes the importance of
this moment for Baby.
Part II: The Getaway
The second part of the scene consists of a
car chase. There are 164 shots spread over
three minutes and 5 seconds. This gives us
an average shot length of 1.19 seconds. Other
than the 23 second final tracking shot, the
longest shot during the chase is six seconds
long. The shortest is 4 frames long. 1/6th
of a second long.
This speed of cutting works here because the
scene functions almost more as a musical montage
of a car chase, than as a real time depiction
of a car chase. There are many apparent jumps
in time, some small some large, but this all
seems to work because of the strong role the
music plays. The chase operates first as a
dance, choreographed to the music, and second
as a depiction of vehicles in geography.
If you turn down the sound design and watch
the scene with just the music, you can see
clearly how the scene is constructed in conjunction
with the music. It doesn't just complement
the scene, it drives it forward.
But it doesn’t lose a real sense of direction
either, there are many clues that allow the
audience to follow the action, and the geography
can be picked up on in repeat viewings. But
Edgar Wright prioritizes showing the feeling
of the scene over clarity of physical action.
Like in this shot where we don’t see the
car swerve over into another lane, but we
can almost feel it swerve because we can see
the movements and reactions of everyone in
the vehicle.
Of like this moments a few seconds later where
we never actually see the car make a u turn,
but a shot of baby pulling the handbrake,
and the passengers bodies shifting in their
seats as the car turns is enough to clue us
into what happened.
And it’s striking, just how much time the
camera spends inside the car.
59 shots of are of baby or the passengers.
While 78 shots are of the actual cars. While
there are still more shots from outside the
vehicle, this 60/40 split still places much
of the emphasis on what’s going on inside
the vehicle.
This chase to me lands closer to the effect
of being in a car chase like this, or driving
a getaway car like this. It’s less like
the experience of merely watching one. Because
of this it sacrifices some of the clarity
of geography, but for good reason. There are
52 shots of Baby’s subaru by itself, and
30 shots of just Baby, the majority of the
the scene is built around one thing. Baby
and his car. The police even take a huge backseat,
only getting incorporated into about 25 shots.
Often their lights appear as clear reminders
of the danger encroaching on baby. Or more
subtly, in a reflection, to remind us they’re
right on his tail. But not much time is spent
focus on that. Most of the time is spent on
Baby’s driving, and the passenger’s responses
to it. Like this moment, which takes an early
step towards endearing us to the character
played by Jon Hamm.
Or these looks from Jon Bernthal’s character
that give us an early indication of his skepticism
towards Baby.
This to me is what sets this scene apart.
It’s singular focus, Baby and his Car, mirrors
the singular focus of the film, Baby and his
Driving. The interior shots that focus on
baby don’t just show him driving, they show
him making decisions that allow him to get
away. We constantly see him assessing the
situation and adjusting. Often in chase scene
like this, the lead car just seems to be following
a predetermined path. But in this scene it’s
clear that they are able to get away because
of Baby’s clever driving.
Baby’s car spins and skids through downtown
Atlanta, Wright constantly shifting the direction
of action so that things don’t feel linear,
but winding and turning, more like a dance.
Wright’s directing is showcased in this
scene. It’s not just a big flashy action
opener to get you hooked. It does all that,
but while it does, subtly it feeds the audience
information that will help them navigate the
story ahead.
Thanks to squarespace for sponsoring this
video. I used squarespace to rebuild my website.
Squarespace takes so much of the pain out
of designing and running a website that you
can really focus on simply bringing your ideas
to life. Their beautiful templates give you
a great starting place and from there you
can customize your site easily to fit your
needs. A website can be a great step in making
your idea or project a reality, so whatever
it is Make your next move with squarespace.
Start your free trial today, at Squarespace.com
and enter offer code THOMASFLIGHT to get 10%
off your first purchase.